wo ist dein weg
ah ja
schau dir das fahrrad an nico
wunderschön oder als ich nach
deutschland gekommen bin hatte ich auch
so ein fahrrad das ist leider irgendwann
kaputt gegangen ist es nicht auch kaputt
was na ja das fahrrad sieht aus wie
schrott weiß ja nicht was er da sagt
nein das weiß wirklich nicht was ich in
meinem alter war also von diesem short
geträumt nico das ist otto
er sammelt fahrräder ich sammle viel zu
viel
deshalb verkaufe ich manche dinge am
liebsten an so nette menschen wie abba
hallo ich bin nico der neffe von yara
ich wollte mich unhöflich sein ist schon
gut was ist denn so besonders an diesem
parat das ist ein altes fahrrad aus der
deutschen demokratischen republik
seit der wiedervereinigung gibt es die
ddr nicht mehr jetzt hab ich in der
schule gelernt und dieses klapprad wurde
in der ddr produziert als das land noch
gab
dieser tipp wird heute gar nicht mehr
gebaut sagten sie klappt ja weil man es
zusammen klappen kann passau
aber vorsicht nicht dass es jetzt noch
kaputt gehen dieses fahrrad ist ein
stück geschichte ja so wie ich bin ich
nicht gleich wasser
machs gut otto und vielen dank das
fahrrad bedeutet mir viel
das ist gut drauf
tschüss
so stabil ist es nicht
gespottet
[Musik]